what separates a champion from a
contender the ability to adapt to learn
from every performance regardless of the
outcome and the discipline to never stop
working in the quest for greatness
that's the same approach we took when
mapping out UFC two we took a close look
at the areas where we dominated an even
closer look at the ones that needed work
and most importantly we look to you our
fans to hear your thoughts our number
one goal is not only to build a great
game but build a game that you will love
like any fighter looking to build out
their last performance we made it a
priority to sharpen our fundamentals
before stepping back into the Octagon
the payoff is the smoothest most
responsive set of movements ever
available in an MMA game that will add
new dimensions to your stand-up ground
game and everything in between no matter
how you choose to take the fight to your
opponent our all new physics driven
reactions make every impact and every
finish unique and let you bring the
sports jaw-dropping moments to life in
the most realistic and rewarding ways
possible what happens inside the Octagon
is up to the fighter but the training
and preparation that gets them there is
just as important to finding success
then you can expect a lot of support in
your corner for UFC two from technique
honing challenges to mid-fight feedback
to risk-free sparring sessions our goal
is to give you the necessary tools to
Master MMA being a well-rounded fighter
also means showcasing diversity and
we're always looking for new ways to
approach a fight we've set our sights on
adding a host of new online and offline
experiences aimed at giving every fight
fan a way to play that keeps them
engaged excited and up-to-date with the
real world of the UFC every time they
pick up a controller and finally you
have to look the part if you want to
raise the belt so we've added thousands
of new and signature animations to take
our athletes to new visual heights we're
also bringing you our deepest and most
powerful fighter creation tools yet
allowing you to bring your imagination
to life and put it on display on MMA's
biggest stage from the walkout to the
knockout will bring you the most
dazzling heart pounding UFC experience
you can imagine so stare back at your
opponent bite down on your mouthpiece
and come out swinging because it's time
to finish the fight
you